let's take a closer look at some emotion
words that are commonly mixed up or used
incorrectly did you ever think about the
difference between jealousy and envy
Maya sees Isabella and Evelyn out for
coffee Isabella is her best friend and
didn't invite her why is she hanging out
with Evelyn and not her Maya feels
jealous now consider Kate Kate sees Maya
at school in a brand new designer
outfit Kate could never afford that
outfit Kate is envious of Maya she wants
what Maya has we are jealous when we
think someone we care about like someone
else more than us but we feel Envy when
someone else has something we want or
desire but can't have another example is
shame and guilt
Brandon was bothering Jose during
morning work
imagine if the teacher Miss Jones said
in front of the whole class Brandon you
are never quiet you'll never pay
attention you're impossible Brandon
feels shame after Ms Jones reprimands
him in front of the class he feels
humiliated and begins to believe that he
is a bad student now imagine if Ms Jones
had said Brandon I asked you to pay
attention to the morning work on your
table did I just see you poking Jose
your behavior makes it hard for the
other students to learn
Brandon feels bad about how he behaved
he feels guilty that his actions may
have distracted his classmates
other examples of commonly mixed-up
words are frustrated and hopeless
satisfied and relieved excited and
elated
[Music]
you
[Music]